[Música]
Hola soy Natalia Cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí a América y Estos
son nuestros temas de hoy en medio de la
peor crisis de su mandato del presidente
de Ecuador Guillermo lasso entregó el
informe de sus dos años de gestión como
disolvió la asamblea no pudo hacerlo
ante ella en su discurso defendió
precisamente la decisión de aplicar el
mecanismo de muerte Cruzada al
legislativo que iba a votar su
destitución y que implica que habrá
elecciones anticipadas les contamos más
con eneldo especial de France 24 a Quito
el gobernador de Florida ron de santis
desafió a Donald Trump y anunció que
aspira a ser el candidato republicano a
la casa blanca el anuncio lo hizo en
Twitter que no funcionó durante la
sesión en vivo lo que generó burlas
mientras en las calles de Miami había
protestas porque el funcionario ha
impulsado varias políticas anti derechos
en ese estado y terminamos en Sao Paulo
donde el auge de una droga sintética
preocupa a las autoridades Pues podría
generar una epidemia por lo que ya hay
varios centros de tratamiento un equipo
de France 24 llegó hasta esta ciudad
brasileña
íbamos de inmediato a Ecuador para
nuestra historia principal el presidente
Guillermo lasso defendió su decisión de
disolver la asamblea nacional que iba a
reunirse para dar un voto clave que
podía llevar a su destitución en un
juicio político por corrupción lo hizo
durante la rendición de cuentas de su
mandato que justamente debía realizar
ante la asamblea que disolvió fue su
segundo y último informe de gobierno
precisamente del presidente ecuatoriano
defendió la legalidad del mecanismo
conocido como muerte Cruzada y arremetió
contra los legisladores escuchemos parte
de su discurso
fin a una confrontación política que
tenía inmerso al país en una crisis que
se agudizaba con el tiempo lazo llamó
además a un diálogo Nacional de Cara a
las elecciones anticipadas que se
convocan automáticamente tras la
disolución de la asamblea no confirmó en
este discurso si va a ser o no candidato
pero aprovechó para destacar sus logros
en materia económica y en uno de los
problemas que más preocupa a los
Ecuatorianos la seguridad vamos a Quito
con el enviado especial de France 24
Rodrigo cedano Rodrigo que otros
aspirantes se perfilan para estos
comicios
uno de los primeros precandidatos que
conocimos para estas elecciones
extraordinarias de Ecuador el próximo 20
de agosto es Gian topic él hasta ese
momento era un completo desconocido en
Ecuador Es un empresario de seguridad de
Guayaquil que asegura además haber sido
parte de la legión extranjera francesa
ese cuerpo de élite del ejército francés
Con quien ha luchado en África y en la
guerra de Siria asegura que también hizo
parte de las brigadas internacionales en
la reciente Guerra de Ucrania apoyando
al gobierno de kiev un candidato
controversial A quien se le acusa de
violencia de género que él niega pero
también por su admiración al gobierno de
nayib bukele asegura topic que es muy
sencillo acabar con la crisis de
seguridad en Ecuador solamente hace
falta un plan a corto medio y largo
plazo otro de los principales
precandidatos que ya conocemos es yaku
Pérez el candidato indígena que en 2021
fue con el movimiento indique
indigenista pachacútic que este año sin
embargo se ha presentado como candidato
de una coalición de partidos unidad
popular democracia así y somos agua dice
yacu Pérez que no busca ser simplemente
un candidato de izquierdas o de derechas
que busca ampliar la base social y salir
de un gobierno o de lasso o del
correísmo precisamente su anterior
partido pachakutic y la conaye la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas del Ecuador tienen un
precandidato él es leónidas iza un
candidato de marcado carácter
izquierdista ingeniero ambiental que ha
sido muy crítico con jacu Pérez y la
dirección de pachacútec Durante los dos
años de legislatura que acabaron con la
muerte Cruzada decretada por lasso
buscan Además desde este movimiento un
frente amplio de movimientos sociales de
izquierdas para llegar a la presidencia
y nos vamos a Estados Unidos porque el
gobernador de Florida ron de santis
lanzó un desafío al expresidente Donald
Trump y competirá por la candidatura del
partido republicano de la presidencia
para las elecciones de 2024 se trata del
único entre la manada de aspirantes que
realmente tendría posibilidades de
arrebatarle la candidatura republicana
debido a que se acerca el discurso Ultra
conservador pero no es el mismísimo
Trump que algunos de los republicanos
consideran no debe ser el candidato
presidencial del partido debido a sus
problemas con la justicia y los
resultados de su primer mandato el
anuncio de santis llegó a través de los
espacios de audio en vivo de Twitter de
la mano de elon musk pero el gran
momento terminó siendo un fiasco debido
a que la conexión se perdió en varias
oportunidades esto generó burlas en las
redes sociales de Santi se evitó hacer
una mención directa a Trump pero sí
mostró un Estados Unidos apocalíptico
bajo el liderazgo de Joe biden
escuchemos parte de lo que logró
comunicar para anunciar su campaña
Bueno estoy compitiendo por ser el
presidente de Estados Unidos para
liderar el gran regreso de Estados
Unidos miren sabemos que nuestro país va
en la dirección equivocada lo vemos con
y lo sentimos en nuestros huesos
nuestras frontera Sur ha colapsado las
drogas abundan en el país nuestras
ciudades desaparecieron Por el crimen
que va en ascenso el Gobierno Federal
está creando dificultades para que la
familia promedio mantengan un estilo de
vida de clase media y nuestro presidente
a quien le falta vigor se tambalea de
Cara a los retos de nuestra nación
y desde luego el expresidente Donald
Trump le respondió lo hizo con una serie
de ataques y descalificativos y agregó
incluso que sería peor que el actual
presidente Joe biden lo que deja ver lo
que será una campaña por la candidatura
republicana llena de ataques y de
retórica y un eventual debate en el que
seguramente le ganará en expresión oral
escuchemos al Magnate neoyorquino
el mojigato ron y sus números en las
encuestas van en caída libre diría que
son récord La pregunta es ron un joven
inexperto e ingenuo más problemas un
tonto que no tiene ni idea de qué
demonios está haciendo ya tenemos uno de
esos en la oficina oval No necesitamos a
otro necesitamos hacer a Estados Unidos
grande de nuevo eso es lo que queremos
si no tenemos selección es la última
oportunidad que tenemos y si no lo
hacemos nuestro país está en un gran
problema realmente
y mientras este cruce de declaraciones
tenía lugar en internet en las calles de
Miami los ciudadanos salieron con
pancartas a rechazar la candidatura de
desantis Y es que como gobernador de
Florida ha sido responsable de varias
políticas de ultraderecha xenófobas y
antiderechos miren prohibió la
interrupción del embarazo después de las
seis semanas de gestación prohibió a las
escuelas dar orientación sexual y
enseñar sobre identidad de género y
prohibió a los ciudadanos chinos cubanos
y venezolanos comprar tierras en Florida
además retomó La promesa de Trump de
construir el muro en la frontera con
México La promesa llevó al presidente
mexicano Andrés Manuel López Obrador a
ignorar su propia retórica de no
intervención en otras naciones y llamó a
los votantes latinos en Estados Unidos a
no apoyar a the santis México es el
principal socio comercial de la Unión
Americana en 2022 representó el 43% de
las importaciones escuchemos a amlo
También aprovecho para decirle al Señor
Santi
politiquería no
de los migrantes era porque quiere ser
el candidato del partido republicano
Entonces ya se destapó
lo que aplicó ya en Florida una política
antimigrante Ojalá y los hispanos de
Florida
Despierten y no le den ni un voto y
vamos a Argentina para revisar otras
noticias de las Américas esta semana
se cumplieron 20 años del kirchnerismo
el 2003 llegó a la casa rosada del ex
presidente Néstor kirchner y hoy su
esposa Cristina es la actual
vicepresidenta El Aniversario llega en
medio de la división precisamente entre
la exmandataria y el actual Alberto
Fernández quien no fue invitado al acto
de conmemoración durante el
multitudinario evento Cristina Fernández
de kirchner arremetió contra el acuerdo
logrado por Alberto Fernández con el
fondo monetario internacional
y cientos de bolivianos salieron a las
calles de la Paz para exigir acciones
legales en contra de los integrantes de
la Iglesia Católica luego de que se
conocieran denuncias de abuso sexual y
de que un medio de comunicación local
publicara incluso Confesiones de
encubrimiento a las violaciones de
menores por parte de algunos religiosos
los ciudadanos vandalizaron varias
Iglesias
y el parlamento cubano aprobó una ley
para limitar la libertad de expresión en
la isla según la iniciativa solo están
autorizados los medios controlados por
el estado lo que hace ilegales a los
medios independientes que han surgido en
internet en el país comunista en los
últimos años son de tendencia
principalmente crítica al régimen
y nos vamos a San Paulo donde una droga
sintética conocida como k2 o k9 preocupa
a las autoridades de esta ciudad la más
poblada de Brasil esta droga es barata y
Adictiva y el desconocimiento de los
factores que la componen puede provocar
la muerte a los consumidores hace 5 años
el 95% de las incautaciones en esta
metrópoli serán de marihuana y cocaína
ahora las drogas sintéticas han pasado
del 5% al 15%. el informe es del equipo
de France 24 en Brasil
en las calles del centro de San Pablo
centenas de toxicómanos deambulandés
orientados entre abril de 2022 y marzo
de este año cerca de 20.000 fueron
encaminados a centros de tratamiento
como este
abrió sus puertas en abril y ya atendió
a más de 3.500 personas aquí los
cannabinoides sintéticos son cada vez
más frecuentes son drogas
son drogas que tienen una gran potencia
y pueden llevar a los pacientes usuarios
a presentar alteraciones psíquicas
muchos de ellos bajo el efecto de la
droga presentan cuadros de alucinaciones
delirio agitación psicomotor
llamada erróneamente marihuana sintética
esta droga es 100 veces más potente que
el cannabis y puede causar problemas
renales arritmias e incluso la muerte
Este joven acaba de ingresarse
voluntariamente revela que consume el k2
desde hace cuatro años la última vez fue
por la mañana
coloqué una pocahoma
lo coloqué en mi boca una vez y nunca
más lo quité un uso es el fin un solo
uso si corres el riesgo de enloquecer
por ejemplo haces cosas de locos nunca
más vuelves a ser la misma persona nunca
más sea la misma persona entre 2021 y
2023 la policía incautó 35 kilos de
drogas K no es poca cosa una hoja tamaño
A4 así se presenta el fármaco puede
contener 1.200 dosis
en las calles de esta metrópolis hace
tiempo que dejó de ser un fenómeno
incipiente este voluntario pasó la noche
con un joven que tuvo una sobredosis
esta droga está matando a mucha gente a
muchos adolescentes que podrían llegar a
50 a 60 años hoy están perdiendo la vida
con 18 17 16 años por causa de esta
droga
algunos expertos vaticinan una explosión
de este narcótico también llamado Spice
la razón es barato y fácil de producir
en laboratorio Brasil podría enfrentar
en breve una emergencia parecida a la
del crack
y me despido con imágenes de Perú ya que
los payasos Se tomaron las calles de
Lima
bailes bromas y sonrisas inundaron la
capital peruana para marcar la
conmemoración del día del payaso el 25
de mayo los payasos afirmaron que
querían traer alegría en medio de
tiempos difíciles gracias por
acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
América con la producción de Jennifer
Guevara Sigan viendo France 24
[Música]